America's brand new Speaker of the House
his first interview Mr Speaker how good
to see you sir thanks Sean welcome to
Capitol Hill all right two weeks ago did
you did you think have you gotten used
to the word speaker yet I haven't Sean
I've been in the job about 48 hours now
and it's kind of surreal to be honest I
just want to say at the outset here God
be with the law enforcement officers
that are handling that situation in
Maine our our prayers uh have been with
the families of that tragedy everyone
here in the house was dialed in on that
all day and it's really something so um
just address that at the front end be
we'd be remiss if we didn't mention it
well already though you're immersed in
Democrats and this happens with almost
every shooting incident the the
immediate call by the left in this
country we need more gun laws we need
more legislation what's your answer to
that at the end of the day it's the
problem is the human heart it's not guns
it's not the weapons at the end of the
day we have to protect the the right of
the citizens to protect themselves and
that's the second amendment and that's
why our party s so strongly for that I
agree with the comments of of your
guests there this is not the time to be
talking about legislation we're in the
middle of that crisis right now uh but I
just want you to know and I want the
American people to know that all the
members of the house here are deeply
concerned about the families involved
and everyone and we we pray for the law
enforcement officers that are doing that
hard job tonight that most people do not
have the uh bravery to do you talk about
the human heart if somebody really wants
to kill innocent people there's a lot of
ways they can do it Beyond using a gun
um I'm sure this will become a bigger
issues throughout the the the days
moving forward uh is there any any
specific gun law that you would look at
or any new legislation you would look at
well been on the job for 48 hours we'll
see I mean there'll be lots of
discussion as there are after these
heartbreaking tragedies but your point
is well taken I mean you know in Europe
uh and in other places they use vehicles
to mow down crowds at parades where
they've done that here in the United
States it it's it's not the weapon it's
the underlying problem I I believe we
have to address the root problems of
these things and mental health obviously
as in this case is a big issue and we've
got to seriously address that as a
society and as a government and and
there's lots of measures pending on that
as well you got a very warm welcome from
the DNC they said you were a an
anti-abortion Maga extremist Mike
Johnson that was the their first words
welcome you well oh yeah welcome welcome
to the your new job then they went on to
say that you were the co-sponsor of inst
uh to Institute an extreme abortion ban
we'll get into detail Nationwide uh you
want to cut Social Security and Medicare
and here's some free advice from Mike
Johnson and that is uh don't get
comfortable we've been here before this
is the same exact Maga extremism that
the American people uh have already
rejected and they will do it again I
thought that was the warmest welcome you
could ever want from the democat about
that yeah welcome to the job look they
don't they don't know me a lot of these
people don't know me and I think um if
they would talk to some of my colleagues
here even on the other side of the aisle
that have worked with me for the seven
years that I've been on Capitol Hill
they would tell them that those things
are not true um give me a chance let me
let me have a chance to lead here and
you'll see what I'm really about let me
ask you because a lot of people don't
know you and before I get to some really
heavy duty questions issues of great
National importance what do you want
people to know about you um there were
things about you that I learned in the
leadup to this interview um I I didn't
know you didn't act legally adopt a
young 14-year-old but you basically
adopted him it would have taken four
years to finalize it um and he happened
to be African-American and he was your
first son and now you have four other
children and you one of them well this
this son was named Michael your other
14-year-old is Jack and you said some
pretty deep profound things that you
think it is harder for your
African-American son than your
biological son in life are you saying
that's institutional racism in the
country what were you referring to no uh
it's it's a reality though having raised
two 14-year-old boys in in America in
the state of Louisiana um they had
different experiences um and and I'm not
so sure it was all about skin color but
it is about culture and Society uh
Michael the the our first um came from a
really troubled background and had a lot
of challenges Jack on the other hand we
was raised in our household from the the
time he was born and it it just struck
me um Sean that it's a reality that you
know there are different um there are
different paths in life and people have
lots of things they have to overcome and
so it it gives you a lot of empathy it
allows you to see Into the Heart of
people and really try to understand them
better and that that that comes in handy
in this Arena because um we're we're
really expected to hate our uh
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle and and and beat them all the time
as enemies politically speaking um but
you have to recognize that this is a A
system that was built upon disagreement
I mean what the founders intended here
in this legislative context is that
we're going to come to the table with
very different philosophical ideas and
and core principles and we have to arm
wrestle over that and reach consensus to
move the ball forward for the American
people that's what the system is built
upon and right now people are going to
their corners and they're refusing to
talk we've got to get over that I don't
know how we we uh reconcile a lot of
these issues either believe in climate
alarmism or energy Independence how do
you Recon that how do you reconcile
defund dismantle versus funding law
enforcement and no bail laws versus bail
laws how do you reconcile secure Borders
or Sanctuary states or cities uh very
controversial issues and I don't know
where the middle ground is do you see it
there there is uh less and less Middle
Ground over the over the decades the the
parties have grown very far apart
there's a wide Chasm now you know if you
rewound Back 40 or 50 years there wasn't
really a lot of difference between the
Republican and Democrat parties if you
compared their platforms there were
nuances about policy but they believed
in the same things they were trying to
do what's right for the country um you
know the allegation here about some of
our colleagues is that's not really
their agenda and some of them really
would like to uh trade what we have for
a European style socialist form of
government we know that that is a
terrible uh idea so we stand for our
foundational principles what what you
have to do is get down to those core
principles and and argue debate with
your colleagues and use the facts you
know show them the reality
socialism is a dead end communism and
Marxism are terrible things it's been
responsible for the deaths of tens of
millions of innocent people over the
20th century alone right that is not the
path we want to go down America is
different and we are exceptional because
we stand on certain foundational
principles I I said in my speech the
other night that was that last night all
my hours are running together now I
think it was yesterday yesterday um I
talked about the core principles of
American conservatism and that's
individual Freedom limited government
the rule of law peace through strength
fiscal responsibility free markets and
human dignity and under each of those
there would be subcategories but that's
what we stand for I call them the core
principles of American conservatism but
it's really the core principles of
America itself we're different we're
exceptional the reason we the freest
most powerful most successful nation in
the history of the world is because
that's what we stand for and those
values and those principles are under
assault right now and we have to defend
them here every day with everything we
have let me ask you you had a bipartisan
briefing with President Biden hakee Jeff
were there other other leaders were
there you got a phone call from
President Biden um tell us about it
how'd it go well I actually had a a
visit with the president at the White
House today for about 15 minutes or 15
or 20 minutes uh the other parties were
running late so it was he and I sitting
there together um it was a meet and
greet um I'd only met him once before uh
it was cordial and pleasant um I have no
problem with with uh President Biden as
an individual right you respect the
office it's a Biblical admonition that
you give give honor where honor is due
and that's the the honest the respect
that we have for the office but he and I
uh dis agree on almost no policy so we
didn't get into that too much today Sean
but there'll be time for that in the
days ahead is there any one thing you
can think of policy that you would say
he's done a really good job on this or
that I can't I can't I I think it's been
a failed presidency and all the problems
some of those that you've articulated
already at the outset of the program
here uh were caused by policy choices
and that's the problem I have with them
it's it's philosophical look um I'm sure
if you've ever seen my show and I don't
know I didn't ask you if you've ever
watched it um the president in my view
has been struggling cognitively it's a
significant decline that I see um I'm
not sure if you saw the tape the
interview that he gave a gaggle on Air
Force One when he was flying back from
Israel after by the way a lot of Allied
Nations did not want to meet with him
leaders did not want to meet with them
which I found to be a pretty big snub um
I don't know if you saw that tape do do
you see in Joe
Biden a cognitive decline and if so is
that a danger to the country I do I
think most of us do that's reality it's
this is not a personal slight to him it
it has to do with with age and Acumen
and everyone's different everyone ages
differently clearly if you look at a
tape of Joe Biden making an argument in
the Senate Judiciary Committee a few
years ago and you you see a speech that
he delivers now there's a difference um
again I mean it's it's not a a personal
insult to him it's just reality and this
is this is what's concerning to us is
that we we we cannot project weakness of
any kind on the world stage right now
this is a dangerous time for all the
things going on around the world the
world is a Tinder Box a strong America
is good for the whole world and we have
to project strength I mean Reagan used
to remind us all the time it's peace
through strength if if America shows
weakness it invites aggression by our
adversaries and that's what you're
seeing around the world so uh I think
that's a really important thing to
remember and also Sean also remember um
I've been watching your show since I can
as long as as I can remember all I don't
25 years almost love when people tell me
I've been watching you since I've been
in first grade I mean feel really good I
remember when your hair was dark darker
than it was a lot darker by the way
speaker I think you're going to catch up
pretty quick it's already happening
especially with the smaller majority
yeah um already the the press the left
have come at you and come at you hard um
specifically I'll give you two big
issues one on the issue you you once
worked for the alliance defense fund a
Christian advocacy group group and
comments you had made both in writing
and advocacy for this group about
homosexuality calling it sinful
destructive um and and not supporting
gay marriage um quote no clear right to
sodomy in the Constitution you have been
getting hammered on this yeah and I want
to ask you about it I want to know
exactly you know where you stand some of
these comments were 15 years ago I don't
even remember some of them I I was a
litigator that was called upon to defend
the state marriage amendments if you
remember back in the early 2000s I think
it was over 35 States somewhere in that
number that that the people went to the
ballot in their respective States and
they amended their state constitutions
to say marriage is one man one woman
well I was a religious liberty defense
lawyer and I was called to go in and
defend those cases in the courts let me
let me State this very clearly and and
there's been questions about this let me
say where I am anybody that knows me
will tell you this is true I am a rule
of law guy I made a career defending the
rule of law I respect the rule of law
when the Supreme Court issued the
oberfell opinion that became the law of
the land okay I respect the rule of law
but I also genuinely love all people
regardless of their lifestyle choices
this is not about the people themselves
I I am a Bible believing Christian
someone asked me today in the media they
said it's curious people are curious
what does Mike Johnson think about any
issue Under the Sun I said well go pick
up a Bible off your shelf and read it
that's that's my worldview that's what I
believe and so your personal worldw my
personal worldview but here's the thing
everybody comes to the House of
Representatives with deep personal
convictions but all of our personal
convictions are not going to become law
that's this is a a a big body of people
there's 435 members in the house you
have to argue and find consensus and all
of that so I have no agenda other than
what's best for the American people and
to defend the rule of law and that's
what we're doing well then let me ask
you on the issue of abortion where
you've been very pro-life obviously that
comes from your issue is Faith you had
argued against row bad law yes dos
happen yes that that issue now has been
sent back to the States on either one of
these issues gay marriage abortion do
you will in the next 14 months as you're
going to be the Speaker of the House
assuming the motion to vacate never
comes up which I think is awful not
shouldn't be there I think we're going
to change or have a have a higher bar
certainly 25 people instead of just any
one member but on any on those two
issues where they've come at you so hard
and and you're explaining your personal
View and you're kind of bifurcating it
sure or away from your political view do
you see any scenario where either one of
those issues would be an agenda item for
you and the Republicans for the next 14
months or at any point down the line
first of on the marriage issue no one
has discussed that for as long as I can
remember this has been settled by the
Supreme Court in the O Burell opinion in
2015 so right uh that's the decision now
they they changed the definition of
marriage that had been regarded by
basically every Human Society for 5,000
years but when five justices on the
Supreme Court changed it that became the
law of the land I'm a constitutional law
attorney I respect that and we move
forward the abortion issue is different
the the table was just reset with Do's
opinion overturn row which I thought was
one of the worst probably the worst uh
Supreme Court opinion roie Wade yes the
most erroneous Court opinion that had
been so you like it back you like the
states to decide we argued my entire
career for 25 years that the stat should
have the right to do this there's no
National consensus among the people on
what to do with that that issue on a
federal level for certain this we have
such big priorities in this moment right
now Sean we have Israel being attacked
we have unrest we have the Ukraine
situation we've got to deal with we have
China being aggressive we have Iran we
all the meddling and China Russia and
Iran working together this is a
dangerous time the economy is in the
tank the borderers overrun people are
dying from fitel poisoning all of these
issues these are the the Frontline
matters that that have our attention
right now and the rest of these things
they're just using for political attacks
so basically you're saying these issues
will not be coming up and you're going
to focus on the agenda items that you
have laid out already and the ones you
just mentioned which we will go into
some detail with let me ask you one
other question on this and this has come
up as um well controversial you had
authored legislation called the stop the
sexualization of children Act of
2022 okay now I looked deeply into this
act your critics have said or dubbed it
it's a federal don't say a gay measure
by the way the word gay was never in the
Florida legislation In fairness to
Governor DeSantis and yet this when you
look at exactly what this is it would
prohibit the use of federal funds to
develop Implement facilitate or fund any
sexually oriented program event
literature for children under the age of
10 now a lot of our kids in a lot of
school districts around the country they
can't read write do math science they're
not learning history and they certainly
need to learn computers so to the age of
10 very specifically but you're not
talking about anything beyond that no
and if you PLL this anywhere in the
country almost any state any Community
they're going to say moms and dads
should be the ones responsible for
talking about these sensitive issues
with their children not the public
school system I mean I'll take that
debate anywhere at Main Street in any
Town Hall in any city in America I would
love for them to challenge us on that
cuz that's what the American people
believe and that's what I believe let me
ask I I have a lot of question question
as you point out there is a lot going on
in the world right now let me let me
throw some numbers at you cuz I think
they're very important we've got war in
Europe we've got Ukraine and we got
Russia um and it's seems very precarious
there already Joe Biden has given $ 76.8
billion to Ukraine he wants $61 billion
more he wants 14 billion to go to Israel
and I think he and then he wants to put
money on the board order probably to sa
satisfy conservatives in the house and
get their support on Ukraine for example
which seems to be his top priority a big
disparity in the amount of money I have
some criticisms about the issue of
Ukraine number one if you're going to
fight a war you should fight it to win
it I thought the president made a
horrible Mistake by denying migs that
were offered by Poland I think the
president made a horrible mistake trying
to put handcuffs on the Ukrainian Army
led by zolinski on the issue of how they
will fight and what weapons they can and
cannot use used like cluster bombs um I
don't like the fact that Europe doesn't
pay their fair share so they've got 78
billion he wants another 61 billion how
will you deal with the issues that he he
wants to tie all of these issues
together which now gets into the
budgetary process how would you go issue
by issue I told the staff at the White
House today that our consensus among
House Republicans is that we need to
bifurcate those issues I agree with your
assessment in Ukraine and that's why the
American people are demanding some real
accountability for the use of those
dollars now we can't allow Vladimir
Putin to Prevail in Ukraine because I
don't believe it would stop there and it
would probably encourage and Empower
China to perhaps make a move on Taiwan
we have these concerns um we're not
going to abandon them but we have a
responsibility a stewardship
responsibility over the precious
Treasure of the American people and we
have to make sure that the White House
is providing the people with some
accountability for the dollars and we
want to know what the objective there is
what is the endgame in Ukraine the White
House has not provided that I was at the
White House for a couple of hours today
and I told the the staff there that this
is where we are this is where the house
of Republicans are so we're going to
look at isra that kind of money is that
America having a proxy war with Putin
and Russia it's it's a great concern
we've got a a group of our colleagues
here in the house led by Mark Mike
Garcia out of California brilliant uh
legislator and a a Top Gun pilot and
some of our veterans have gotten
together Dan crenchaw is involved in
this and others they came up with a
document that presents 12 critical
questions for the White House to answer
as a condition of our supply and the
additional support these are not hard
questions Sean these are things the
White House should be forthcoming about
I delivered that myself oh you did
deliver it to the presid I delivered it
myself today and and the National
Security adviser Jake Sullivan read it
uh he says he's studying he's going to
study it tonight during the show yes so
we want to be cooperative we need to
work together on this but we we owe it
to the people to know what the plan is
where the money is going to be spent and
we need some auditing for the dollars
that we've already sent over there these
are not tough questions right Israel is
a separate matter we're going to bring
forward a uh Standalone Israel funding
measure over $14 billion 14 billion
enough that well Israel's requested a
little less than that actually the White
House did uh by way of Israel and 14.5
billion specifically is what we're
looking at it's a very specific number
tied to very specific measures but
here's the important thing that
distinguishes House Republicans from the
other team we're going to find pay fors
in the budget we're not just printing
money to send it overseas we're going to
find the cuts elsewhere to do that let
me ask you this in Israel it it's very
complicated I mean Syria is now firing
missiles into Israel the houti rebels
which I don't know why Joe Biden you
know they were once designated a
terrorist group he's taken away that
designation I why I don't know uh they
tried to fire um missiles into um Israel
in the north you have hisbah and you
have Lebanon in the South where Gaza
killed 1,400 including 30 Americans and
Americans are being held hostage um
beyond the money part is is there any
involvement you see or any reason for
any military involvement by the United
States would Congress support that cuz
it seems like with the maneuverings of
our Navy and other indication Special
Forces maybe to rescue American hostages
any movement that you would support that
you can think of now it's a very
delicate situation it changes by the
hour we're watching it very closely one
thing that House Republicans are
resolved on is that we must stand with
our most important allies in the Middle
East and that's Israel um we will I we
we certainly hope that it doesn't come
to boots on the ground um if if it comes
to that and we communicated this to the
White House staff as well today that um
you know we have the article one power
in the legislative branch of government
and they have article two they have very
limited Authority on what they can do to
respond without coming to Congress to
seek consent and even my Democrat
colleagues Sean that are uh Committees
of jurisdiction understand this and the
the Foreign Affairs committee they
there's a purpose for that the reason
the framers put that into the
Constitution is that they wanted a
multitude of wise Council to decide upon
military intervention matters on a
declaration of war they wanted the duly
elected representatives of the people to
make that decision collectively not one
commander-in Chief Sitting in an office
here here's my worst fear worst case
scenario for the Middle East okay there
Israel will be fighting a two-front war
yeah Gaza Hamas and the South yes soon
as they the ground incursion which could
happen any minute begins uh I would
expect
more Rockets to be fired from the north
from Lebanon Hezbollah they have two
they both have something in common that
they're getting military strategy
Weaponry money support from Iran that's
the head of the snake now we have
another problem Syria has involved
itself in this conflict another problem
the houis seem to be wanting to involve
themselves and you've had comments made
by the leaders of Iran that they
themselves may get involved in a
conflict if that happens correct me if
you think I'm wrong I would bet I would
say all bets are off in the Middle East
we could have a full out war in the
Middle East Israel at the center of it
and at that point if Israel's existence
is put in Jeopardy I don't think prime
minister Netanyahu who I've known for
almost 30 years I don't think there's
anything he won't do to pres preserve
and protect his country from people that
have have committed their lives to
destroy it he has to do that and around
here people throw around the phrase
existential threat they have an
existential threat every day I mean
their neighbors want to eliminate them
and wipe them off the map so prime
minister Netanyahu is resolved i' I've
spent time with him personally I know
him as well uh I I I think he's a strong
leader at at this important time and I
think he's going to do what is necessary
and and America will back him up I mean
they tell us when we're in Israel and
you've been there they they say the
reason that we are able to sustain
ourselves and survive is because
everyone knows that our big Ally is
America and that's an important role
that we have in the world we're not the
world's policeman but a strong America
as I said is good for the whole world
because it's the perception that we
would be there to defend freedom and
that's been our role that's the Reagan
Doctrine a lot of our friends in our
party are becoming more isolationist and
understand the concerns we can't be
dropping money out of helicopters all
around the world because we also have a
33.5 trillion doll federal debt of our
own saw a sign on the way in it said
33.6 we go to Six probably from this
afternoon exactly it goes so fast you
can't track it and that's the concern
you know we we we deeply care and are
concerned about all nations of free
people around the world but we have to
take care of our own house first and so
that's also part of this delicate
calculation and and the decision I I've
been to Israel during the flare up in I
believe it was 2014 and at that point I
I got to see upfront and go inside the
terror tunnels that are built by Hamas
by the way the all of the money and
resources that was was given to the
Palestinian people for infrastructure
for schools um and hospitals but they
have this massive network of territories
uh and when you go inside it just is
mind-numbing that this is how they're
spending their time because they want to
kill Israelis or take them hostage and
but it taught me a lot about and being
in border cities one Border City in
particular that wrote you know 10,000
Rockets they've been hit with in 10
years and these kids play indoors in
Bunker uh playgrounds my question to you
is simple it Joe Biden wants to give
$100 million to the Palestinians for
humanitarian relief sounds great on
paper I have zero confidence one penny
will make it to the Palestinian people
because Hamas has been forcing people to
stay and pointing guns and shooting at
the at the Palestinians that want to
leave right they use the Palestinians as
as a Shields they don't even provide the
people with clean drinking water we're
supposed to believe they're going to use
us uh aid for humanitarian purposes
count me as a skeptic okay we we got to
be very careful about what we're doing
there you do not want to further empower
the terrorist groups our heart goes out
to the innocent Palestinian people of
course as we do to anyone who's in a
terrible situation like that but we have
to be very Discerning in our policy and
in our approach to this and so that's
why we're demanding House Republicans
are demanding more information from the
white house so that we can help and make
these critical decisions look we're
going to stand by Israel but we have to
be careful in how it's done what about
the 100 million for humanitarian relief
of the Palestinians I I I think it's a
tough issue I mean we're going to have
to see what that is tied to and I'll
tell you the house Democrats of course
are very Resolute on that and they try
to portray us as being uncaring look we
care about that as well but we have to
be very careful that we're not further
funding terrorist organizations that are
trying to wipe Israel off the map can
you explain why then President Obama
Vice President Biden did this billion
dollar deal with Iran can you explain
why Joe Biden made a deal with the
Iranians for $6 billion to be freed up
in money that was held that they had no
access to we're yeah we're in fits over
that I I I don't understand it at all I
don't understand most of their foreign
policy and I think it's gotten Us in the
shape that we're in we have big
disagreements with them uh we're we're
asking for uh an and demanding
accountability on that as well and we
have to the White House has to improve
how they're messaging this and how
they're explaining it to the people
because we we all have to understand
that we have a right to this is the the
precious Treasure of the American people
and and if you're sending Iran money we
know that Iran is directly tied to all
this these are Hamas and Hezbollah are
proxies of Iran and they're tied in now
with Russia and China I mean it is a new
axis of Evil that's how we see it and so
it has to be addressed if Israel with
all the funding of Terror and all these
Terror organizations they within their
right to fight back and go directly at
Iran course of course that was the fir
as you noted the First Act of my
speakership is that we passed that
resolution to to articulate that make it
very clear where we stand the the house
is back in business and we're going to
stand with Israel let's ask I I call it
the new axis of Evil China Russia Iran
yeah how big a threat it's huge it's
it's the biggest threat since World War
II we have been the big kid on the Block
right we're the last real superpower and
and after the uh USSR felll we've been
unrivaled now China is a near
peer-to-peer adversary to us now and of
course their goal is to rebuild the
Empire and so we're doing everything we
can to ensure that we maintain our
military superiority we're the only
nation that has the ability to project
power and force like that around the
globe right now but China is doing its
best to encroach upon that power and you
see they're even putting outposts around
us they're buying up Farmland in in
States here in the US uh all of these
things have to be addressed at the
federal level at the state level with
the legislatures and even in some of
these localities we have Chinese C C CP
owned um companies that are coming in an
open shop on Main Street in some towns
in our small town they're buying our
farmlands they're buying our Ranch Land
and they're buying land near military
installations yes would we be allowed to
buy it there of course not of course not
and and they allowed a you know a
Chinese spy balloon to float unimpeded
across the country for eight days you
know we have we scratch our heads a lot
around here about these Biden decisions
and I don't know it may be tied in some
way to I don't know some of the the
money they receive from some of these
folks well you are on the house Jud
comme we've been watching the house
oversight committee with James comr let
me ask you there's issues involving two
congressmen in particular a Democrat and
a republican uh George Santos the
Republican many charges have have been
filed against him and then the issue of
congresswoman to Le um and and others
and this's talk of censure and talk of
removal you support either we're working
through those issues I'll tell you I
talked to um uh the the authors of some
of these resolutions today that want to
deal with that um here's the reality
Sean we have a four- seat majority in
the house um it it is possible that U
that number may be reduced even more in
the in the coming weeks and months and
so we'll have what may be the most razor
thin majority in the history of the
Congress um we have no margin for error
and so uh George Santos is due due
process right he is uh my understanding
is I think he's appearing in a federal
court uh tomorrow and uh we have to
allow due process to play itself out
that's what our system of justice is for
he's not convicted he's charged
convicted he's charged and so if we're
going to expel people from Congress just
because they're charged with a crime
then um you know or accused that that's
a that's a problem Joe Biden has allowed
over 7 and A5 million people into this
country illegally it'll be probably over
8 million even people on terror watch
list even people from countries like
Iran and Syria um how do you get the
border secure and what is your
assessment of um Secretary of Homeland
Security this uh mayor should he be
impeached uh listen you know that my
duties here have included Judiciary and
the select committee on the
weaponization of the federal government
in my assessment almost every Federal
agency under the bid Administration has
been weaponized that the the very
agencies that were designed to protect
and serve the people are now being used
against them and we have many examples
of that and you've talked about all of
it on your show before look mayorcas has
been an abject failure in his position I
believe he has committed impeachable
offenses and I've been on a record
saying that for a long long time in fact
he appeared uh in oversight Hearing in
our house Judiciary Committee we have
jurisdiction over his Department uh less
than four months into office and I saw
where this was headed and I told him in
a clip it went viral Mr may orcus you
need to get your resume prepared because
uh I I thought he was uh headed towards
a dead end on this uh look the
investigations are going forward Jamie
comr and the oversight committee are
doing an exceptional job Jim Jordan
who's chairman of Judiciary uh has
helped lead on that we we've gotten a
lot of information on all these issues
you're on the Judiciary Committee let me
ask you do you believe that that Joe
Biden's Department of Justice do you
believe our FBI has been politicized do
you believe it's been weaponized do we
have a dual justice system absolutely we
have a two-tiered system of justice and
that that erodes the people's faith in
our system of justice itself and this is
what I reminded Meritt Garland when he
was in front of us the Attorney General
Christopher Ray at the FBI the greatest
threat here is not these individual
issues it's that the people are losing
their faith in our system of Jus and
Sean you cannot maintain a
constitutional republic a government of
by and for the people if the people
doubt that the system is fair you know
if they believe there's two tiers of
Justice then the system doesn't work at
all and so I think Garland's been a
great threat I think he's the worst
attorney general in the history of the
United States Joe Biden sworded the
American people both as a candidate and
as president not not one time did he
ever speak to his son his brother or
anybody for that matter about their
foreign business dealings we know that
is a flat out lie we've learned from
James comr and his investigation that we
are talking about tens of of millions of
dollars taken in from a lot of
adversarial countries some of our top
geopolitical foes like China yeah Russia
uh Ukraine uh Romania Mexico other
countries tens of millions they've
discovered all of these um shell
corporations they've discovered nine
particular Biden family members have
been paid and then you have the issue of
Joe on tape admitting that he F used our
money taxpayer money to leverage a
billion dollars in loan guarantees which
was Obama administration policy to fire
a prosecutor investigating his son well
one of the benefits of that his son
continued to get paid for a job he
admits he had no experience in at a time
where he was dealing with a drug problem
that sound that s sound like to you
that's a pretty good recitation of the
facts and as John Adams said facts are
stubborn things they're hard to ignore
uh I I believe uh the documents are
proving all that as as my good brother
Jamie comr often says the bank records
don't lie so we have the receipts on
some much of this now it's a real
problem that's the reason that we
shifted into the impeachment inquiry
stage on the president himself because
if if in fact all the evidence leads to
where we believe it will that's very
likely impeachable offenses you know
that's listed as a cause for impeachment
in the Constitution you know bribery and
uh other high crimes and misdemeanors
briber is listed there and and uh it
looks and smells a lot like that and I
think the evidence we're going to follow
the truth where it leads we're going to
engage in due process because again
we're the rule of law party I know
people are getting anxious and they're
they're getting restless and they just
want somebody to be impeached but that's
not we don't do that like the other team
we have to we have to base it upon the
evidence and the evidence is coming
together we'll see where it leads let me
go back to the budget if I may for a
second um this whole issue of regular
order we have four of the 12
Appropriations bills that have already
been dealt with that my understanding is
that's about 70% of the budget so you
have eight more to go um you've talked
about a short-term
CR uh that you would be willing to maybe
have until January or maybe even until
April would there be we talk about a
clean CR would you have conditions for
example chip Roy and Byron Donalds had a
plan okay well we'll give you a CR but
it's not going to be clean we're going
to cut government spending by 8% and
we're going to secure the border and
protect our military and and Veterans
would you would you have conditions to a
CR I think we have to if indeed we do
that November 17th of course is the
deadline that was extended you got about
coming quickly 21 days and and the we're
speeding it up as quickly as possible
that was my commitment to my colleagues
when they Nam me speaker of the house
and and that work began today in fact we
passed one of the approach bills just a
couple hours ago before you arrived here
uh we we got it off the house for the
energy and water bill uh that was a big
uh box that we had to check and we did
that and so uh we're going forward a
chip and buy in are at the table with
others we're working through this with
the ideas and trying to ensure that if U
another stop G measure is required that
we do it with certain conditions and I
think there'll be conditions the
American people can live with and and
the consensus that we can build around
here in the house let me let me ask you
this we have two-thirds of this country
now a living paycheck to paycheck yes
many of those people can't afford Bare
Necessities I I know Biden's been
crowing about bomic I know they got good
numbers today however a lot of e
economists I spoke to earlier today this
doesn't look good at all they think in a
bubble that is about to burst and it's
going to be even worse especially in the
housing market it's new home
construction is stopping sale of
pre-existing homes a
disaster how bad is this economy how
long can we sustain another what two
trillion in in debt that Joe Biden took
on last year and how do we get inflation
down once and for all I have friends of
mine just three years ago they were
getting interest rates at three a 30e
fix rate Mortage at 30% now it averages
8% nobody's going to sell their their
home and buy another home at that
because it's thousands of dollars more
for the same type of home it grinds the
economy to a Hal it's a disaster that's
the word you use and that's the
appropriate word these are policy
choices that got us in this situation if
you remember if you rewind in your mind
back to um uh right before the pandemic
began you know in the Trump
Administration we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world uh
and it wasn't by happen stance it's
because we cut taxes cut regulations we
focused on American Energy dominance we
were doing and following all the
policies that led to economic success
and growth for all Americans everyone
and every demographic all Boats were
Rising we can achieve that again but you
have to do almost exactly the opposite
of what the Biden Administration is
pursuing and doing this is not rocket
science but we're so far down the road
now that we have to make these changes
quickly and we're trying to urge our
Democratic colleagues to take a look
again at the basic facts I mean interest
rates are so high now they're going to
continue to rise apparently digit I can
see it coming right let let me ask maybe
the question this way because you do
have such a small majority and and
obviously that didn't help Kevin
McCarthy I think you should get rid of
the motion to vacate and raise the bar
dramatically 20 25 people at least my
question is specifically on the economy
if you pass your budgets in the house
you're going to send it over to the
Senate they're going to rip it up line
by line you'll go into conference but
the only way you can succeed is if you
as Speaker are able to hold your slim
majority yes that's going to be herculan
task how do you plan on doing that I um
with truth and transparency and and
relationships you know this is a
business that's based on that and uh my
colleagues trust me I'm grateful for
that um it's earned and uh I I'm going
to do well by them or we're going to
govern well we're going to show the
American people we can you know when you
get into the negotiations in the
conference committee the the speaker of
the house and the leader of our party
has to have a strong hand and so if we
can keep the team together keep rowing
in the same direction look everybody's
got to give up on some of their
preferences none of us are going to get
everything we want we never I'll never
ask any of my colleagues to compromise
core principles because I share those
principles with them right U but Ronald
Reagan used to teach us I'd rather get
80% of what I want than go over the
cliff with a flag waving I still believe
in that idea and I'm very optimistic I
am bullish on the future of America I am
bullish on our chances to change the way
Works Sean we have a once in a-lifetime
opportunity here that's the vision I've
cast to my colleagues I believe it to my
core we're going to take this day byday
decision by decision but keep everybody
together and move the ball forward for
the American people I I genuinely
believe that we can get this done one of
the things that I have said over and
over again to anybody that'll listen
although I can look in this camera and
say honestly nobody ever listens to me
not true not true but I try is it's my
strong belief that all Republicans
you're either going to win together or
you're going to be in the eyes of the
American people you're going to win on
your agenda or you're going to lose and
I don't see any way of winning if you
don't all stick together I know you have
these this dispar group of uh egos if
you will I hope everybody will maybe
hear your
admonition and work together as a team
and go forward you know fix our border
can we become energy dominant and maybe
start paying down our debt um can we
come up with sound foreign policy to
help out our allies in a time of you
know a dire time for them I mean these
challenges are Run Deep and then you
have the issue of Law and Order safety
security open borders pretty scary times
do you think this country is in Decline
I I think right now we're in very
desperate times I think the hour is late
and the crisis is great but here's why
I'm encouraged in previous generations
of Americans from the framers the
founders of this country all the way
through at times the revolutionary
period the Civil War the Great
Depression the other world wars when the
leaders here got in trouble that was
beyond the scope of what they could
solve themselves individually or
collectively you know what they did they
saw Divine guidance for it we have in
God we trust right above the roster room
there and I pointed that out in my
speech is this the the Ben Franklin
moment it is a Ben Franklin mon
constitutional exactly right it's the
same thing and we're we're we're calling
one another to to Humble ourselves and
recognize that the challenges are so
great but that's where a real
opportunity is presented I believe that
God has not done with America yet okay
still believe in that motto it's not
just a a quaint saying to me it's what
the nation was founded upon this belief
it's what distinguishes us from all
these other communist Marxist socialist
countries around the world it's the key
to our our greatness and we ought to
appeal to that and I believe if we do um
that that that God is going to give us
his favor and I believe we're going to
solve these problems I I did ask you
before the show and I'll make this the
last question and I said because I
believe that if you take this majority
and you can somehow pull these disparate
groups together I do believe it would be
good for the country cuz as a you know
I'm very clear about my conservatism I
believe those policies are best for our
country and I want the best for our
country this country I've had a life
frankly that's undeserved and I just
really so I asked you I said would it be
okay if it came back when you get
settled you've had less than 48 hours
you we appreciate you doing the
interview um and bring the disparate
groups in a room and do it for an hour
and see what issues that we can find
full agreement on I would like to know
what those issues are and where the
disagreements are you'd be willing to
have us back of course we're working on
that and that's a great admonition look
this place is filled with people of good
faith of deep conviction and they
understand the necessity of working
together there some big OS Mr Speaker
yeah well but Washington has that
sometimes we're going to work through it
I'm optimistic all right Mr Speaker we
appreciate your time thank you that's
thank you for being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else